c'est vrai que après les premiers
speakers la barre est très très haute et
on va essayer de
raconter aussi l'histoire qui est de
rebondir en revenant au pays
c'est vrai que on est peut-être chacun
de se sent pas concernés mais on a tous
été vivre à l'étranger où on a un frère
ou une sœur qui vient à l'étranger donc
on connaît un peu
cette histoire
comme la plupart de ceux qui sont là il
y a une bonne partie qui ont étudié à
l'étranger certains ont vécu à
l'étranger sans faire des études
peut-être mais on a tous l'ambition en
fait un jour de revenir servir le pays
après
il y a cette motivation cette ambition
il y a la réalité du terrain il y a le
fait de revenir comment est-ce qu'on
procède parce que on se dit qu'on
revient au pays ça a l'air facile c'est
comme quand on vit à qu'on a cru on
retourne au village il y a des choses
qui changent on se sent petit à petit
étranger dans son propre pays
et le choix aussi n'est pas tout à fait
aisé parce que
des fois on a une situation on a une
bonne situation
on essaie de c'est comme peut-être
monsieur le diplomate il est en Guinée
l'expatrié il va essayer de rentrer un
jour dans son pays et où il va
rencontrer des difficultés ça n'a pas
l'air évident mais lorsqu'on revient et
que par exemple pour moi quand j'ai
décidé de revenir pour des raisons qui
me sont personnelles il y avait le fait
de participer au développement du pays
et le fait aussi de voir mes enfants
grandir en Guinée aux côtés des
grands-parents et avoir la culture
guinéenne et c'est des choses en fait
qui ne sont pas faciles parce que à un
moment donné il faut faire un choix et
lorsqu'il faut faire un choix on pèse le
pour et le contre et même actuellement
il y a beaucoup de grains qui reviennent
ils repartent au 6 mois donc cela veut
dire quoi il faut
d'abord être mentalement dans la
disposition de vouloir revenir et se
préparer et quand on revient également
il faudrait se préparer se préparer sur
le plan financier parce que quand on
revient on n'a pas toujours l'emploi ou
en tout cas l'insertion que nous
souhaitons avoir
des fois au bout de quelques mois il y a
eu des amis et moi-même j'ai procédé à
des allers-retours dans un premier temps
avant de venir complètement me
stabiliser en Guinée donc
en tout cas ce qui est
on a souvent des défis par rapport à
cela et
d'abord c'est le fait de se sentir
étranger dans son propre pays je
m'explique à dire vous revenez moi le
premier entretien que j'ai eu c'était
par rapport à un projet m'avait dit
qu'on me donnait pas le poste parce que
je connaissais pas le pays je
connaissais pas la Guinée donc vous
voyez un Guiné vous revenez en Guinée on
vous dit que vous ne connaissez pas le
pays effectivement quand je réfléchi se
trouvait que par rapport à ce que
je connaissais pas l'administration
Guinée c'était par rapport à
l'administration guinéenne j'ai quitté
la Guinée pendant une certaine période
donc l'administration guinéenne je la
connaissais pas et il fallait avoir ce
choc et accepter vraiment d'avoir un
poste qui est sous-dimensionné vous
pouvez apprendre en fait
réapprendre l'administration guinéenne
sur insérer dans son pays et c'est ce
que j'ai fait dans un premier temps par
la suite j'ai eu d'autres opportunités
qui m'ont permis
d'avoir d'autres d'autres postes plus
importants on a des défis également par
rapport
à la vision en fait de ce que les autres
ont comme perception vis-à-vis de
quelqu'un qui revient c'est quelqu'un
peut-être qui se dit qu'il connaît tout
et au niveau de
en tout cas partout on est stigmatisé on
est stigmatisé on a du mal à se
réinsérer et il faudrait beaucoup de
persévérance et beaucoup de réadaptation
pour pouvoir réellement se rincerer par
rapport
au défi également et surtout les
les éléments qu'il faut prendre en
compte pour ne pas repartir parce que le
challenge c'est un peu ça c'est de
pouvoir
c'est-à-dire c'est de pouvoir avoir la
force de
s'intégrer comme on a été avant de
partir c'est-à-dire avant de partir tu
avais une idée une vision de la de là où
tu es tu reviens tu retrouves un nouveau
contexte et peut-être des fois
actuellement par exemple s'il vous
prenez des gens qui ont eu des
nomination ils sont là il y a beaucoup
qui veulent repartir parce que ils n'ont
pas les conditions de vie qu'ils avaient
en Occident même si
il se trouve que ils sont dans leur
propre pays ils ont du mal à
se rincer parce qu'ils ont des doubles
dépenses il y en a qui ont contracté de
près il y en a qui il faut vivre ici et
pouvoir encore honorer tous les
engagements qu'on a de l'autre côté donc
cette double vie cette vie
dans des côtés n'est pas facile vraiment
à mener de façon
en tout cas en même temps donc ce que
moi je j'ai eu comme expérience ce que
je conseillerais vraiment c'est de
pouvoir
bien préparer son projet avant de
revenir faire des
allers-retours pour mieux connaître le
reconnaître le contexte dans lequel on
se réinsère et par la suite aussi
accepter des emplois de foi ou en tout
cas d'échec d'échouer dans son projet
dans l'entrepreneuriat par exemple ou
bien accepter des postes qui sont moins
rémunérés moins valorisant par rapport à
ce qu'on avait cela permet de rebondir
et de pouvoir en fait se réinsérer et
participer au développement de son pays
en termes de
en tout cas de
conseils que je vais donner c'est de
pouvoir chacun à son cheminement et dans
ce cheminement on a des obstacles et
c'est de bien préparer en fait
comment comment lever ses obstacles il y
a des histoires qui sont beaucoup plus
reduisant on a des expatriés qui
reviennent avec un travail bien assuré
mais c'est pas toujours le cas donc
en conclusion je dirais que par rapport
au retour au pays il faut pouvoir
s'adapter c'est le maître mot que moi je
vais conseiller il faut une capacité
d'adaption énorme et ne pas en tout cas
avoir les idées reçues qu'on a toujours
c'est à dire
on te décourage tout le temps quand tu
veux rentrer quand tu veux rentrer on te
décroche tout le temps donc les idées
reçues il faut venir vivre et vivre
vraiment au niveau de
sur le terrain les expériences des uns
et des autres et pouvoir également
comparer entre la vie qu'on a là-bas et
la vie qu'on a ici sachant que c'est pas
le même contexte il y aura toujours des
éléments de différence et accepter ces
différences et aussi bien préparé son
projet avec sa famille si on a une
famille pour parce que souvent c'est
quand on a une famille on a ses
difficultés si on a tout seul on peut
bon dire revenir mais quand on a une
famille bien décidé avec la famille
parce que ça crée des fois quand même
des drames par rapport au retour donc
chers amis c'est ce que j'avais à
partager avec vous je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]